from action flick to rom-com everyone
has that one movie that no matter how
many times they've seen it before it
they just can't resist watching it again
maybe it's the awesome plot or amazing
effects or maybe it's just one singular
scene that draws people back in again
and again what makes these scenes worthy
of repeat viewings see for yourself
rosebud with one whispered word Orson
Welles single-handedly invented the
concept of the mind-blowing twist in
Demon's Citizen Kane is considered by
many to be the greatest film ever made
and it holds up remarkably well
but it's the twist at the end that keeps
viewers coming back with his last dying
breath Charles Foster Kane reminds us
that despite the wealth and power he has
amassed nothing can compare to his
innocent and happy childhood I don't
think any word can explain a man's life
no I guess but just a piece of a jigsaw
puzzle the reveal of what rosebud
actually meant and the fact that no one
in the world of the film will ever
understand it comes as a profoundly
emotional shock rosebud is it's fled it
was his sled from when he was a kid
considering how many times this film has
been parodied there's no denying its
cultural imprint especially in today's
nostalgia obsessed climate
[Music]
the shock of a lifetime Jackie Chan is
no stranger to death-defying stunts the
action star claims to have broken nearly
every bone in his body and that's not
hard to believe if you've seen any of
his movies but all his jumps kicks flips
and flails pale in comparison to his
signature stunt in Police Story known as
perhaps the greatest stunt in movie
history it features Cham jumping off a
balcony sliding down a pole and crashing
through live electrical wires and plate
glass the stunt is so iconic that the
film shows it three times in a row from
three different angles Chan ended up
electrocuting himself dislocating his
pelvis and cutting himself on the glass
if this dedication isn't worth a few
dozen viewings then nothing is fool
fantasies at ridgemont high in the
history of cinema
no single moment has turned more boys
into men than phoebe cates slow-mo strut
from the pool and Fast Times at
Ridgemont High it's pretty obvious why
this is one of the most rewatched scenes
of all time you know how cute is and
it's not just about a beautiful girl
strutting around in a bikini it's funny
too after Brad's fantasy the audience
has then shown the cold hard
embarrassing reality of the situation
for anyone who's ever been a teenager
and loved this scene is relatable iconic
and totally rewatchable a real trouper
no one understands better than George
Lucas how difficult it is to make a
movie but I did have a vision but my
vision was way beyond what was possible
and I did the best I could he did so
many things wrong in his original Star
Wars trilogy that he went back in and
fixed them by fixed we mean of course
jam the movie so full of special effects
that audiences can barely find any trace
of the original actors or sets in some
scenes but one iconic scene was actually
improved by Lucas's meddling decades of
jokes had been made at the expense of
the poor stormtrooper who banged his
head on the doorway
Lucas even added a bonk sound effect to
emphasize the moment for the special
edition release the whisper heard round
the world lost in translation was one of
the most original and oddly romantic
movies to come out in years however it
left audiences scratching their heads
with its final scene Bill Murray's
morose acting legend is saying goodbye
to Scarlett Johansson's lonely newlywed
while they share a wonderful friendship
it is clear that they'll
ever see each other again then Murray
leans in close and whispers something in
Johansson's ear
you can hear that he's whispering but
what he actually said was too quiet for
the mics to pick up there are tons of
theories but it looks like whatever
Murray said to Joe Hanson is stayin
between them even director Sofia Coppola
was kept in the dark that mysterious
whisper and the rest of this beautiful
and poignant film has kept audiences
coming back for over a decade
a head spinning ending there's nothing
more maddening than an ambiguous ending
and no ambiguous ending was more
maddening than that of Inception
Christopher Nolan's action-adventure
dream heist as Leonardo DiCaprio's dream
thief Dom Cobb finally returns home to
his children he sets a top spinning on
the dining-room table he runs off to
greet his children but the camera goes
back to the top which was established
earlier in the film as a tool for Cobb
to tell whether he was awake or still
dreaming if he was in a dream the top
would spin forever without falling just
when the top is about to fall the movie
cuts to black Nolan has never confirmed
any of the extensive fan theories that
have come up perhaps that's the point
trapping you in an endless loop where
you will never know how the story ends
or maybe it's just a cool ending one
morose Munchkin following the yellow
brick road sure is fun that is until you
get old enough to start noticing what's
dangling just through the trees as
familiar as The Wizard of Oz is to
multiple generations of fans one aspect
of the film remained hidden to all but
the most egalitarian from a noose in the
background while our merry band of
travelers skipped into the distance the
studio eventually denied this claiming
that it was just a bird when the
remastered version was released in 1998
the rumor was debunked as the figure in
the distance was indeed just a bird
still stranger things have happened
somewhere over the rainbow thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel please
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]